[Música]
bueno empezamos a nuestra sección de
salud más romeros a la bienvenida feliz
martes vamos a empezar en eeuu la
campaña de bayer recibió en la compañía
mejor dicho así un revés judicial por su
controvertido producto de glifosato tan
polémico además sí buenos días revolver
no es la primera vez ni será
probablemente la última que esta
compañía que recordemos que una de las
farmacéuticas más grandes del mundo se
ve en enredos judiciales por el
glifosato en este caso estamos hablando
de que la corte suprema de estados
unidos rechazó dos apelaciones de bayer
en contra de sentencias de tribunales de
menores una fue ayer y la otra fue la
semana pasada son ciudadanos
estadounidenses que desarrollaron cáncer
y que entonces pues denunciaron a la
compañía porque asocian este cáncer a su
producto roundup este que están viendo
aquí que es un herbicida que contiene el
componente activo del glifosato las
sentencias que están intentando evitar
bayern son realmente millonarias que
cáncer desarrollaron estos pues estos
pacientes y estas personas que
trabajaron prolongadamente con el
glifosato cáncer de linfoma nov tienes
un cáncer que empieza en los glóbulos
blancos recordemos que son parte del
sistema inmune de nuestro cuerpo y que
pues así no como todos si no se detectan
a tiempo pueden tener consecuencias
serias incluso la muerte en la salud
recordemos también un par de datos mas
bayern es la empresa que compró monsanto
en 2016 y también recordar que una de
las farmacéuticas que produce productos
tan amplio están ampliamente usados en
el mundo como la aspirina o el antiácido
alka seltzer
claro marc hablamos mucho del glifosato
pero que realmente es y por qué
o si es de verdad dañino si vamos a
analizar un poco los datos que se tienen
hasta ahora para hablar sobre bases
científicas es el componente activo como
decíamos el glifosato de muchísimos
herbicidas no solo de roundup que sirven
pues para matar la maleza por ejemplo y
ayudar a los agricultores a que sus
cosechas se desarrollen sin que otras
plantas acumulen recursos que deberían
estar dedicadas a esta agricultura y la
verdad es que para responder a tu
segunda pregunta todavía no hay un
consenso claro sobre los efectos del
glifosato sobre la salud por ejemplo
qué es la agencia ambiental de estados
unidos ha concluido que no que
efectivamente no es un problema para la
salud sin embargo la agencia de
investigación de la ms para el cáncer en
2015 dijo que si era probablemente
carcinogénicos qué significa pues que
inicia o que puede propiciar la
aparición del cáncer poco después la
organización mundial de la salud y la
omi es en cambio ser un informe diciendo
que no había estudios estudios
concluyentes y que el más grande y el
más fiable lo que decía era que el
glifosato era poco probable que causara
cáncer a través de la dieta pero
recordemos que la dieta es decir comer
productos que hayan sido tratados con
glifosato es sólo una de las posibles
exposiciones a este producto por último
queríamos incluir un estudio de la
universidad de los grandes aquí en
colombia que estudió el uso del
glifosato en contra los cultivos
ilícitos de coca y concluyeron que
efectivamente si tenía mayores riesgos
de problemas en este caso no para el
cáncer pero sí para la piel para los
sistemas respiratorios y que podría
incluso llegar a inducir abortos
espontáneos y es que esa es la otra
lista no también el efecto
medioambiental que también puede tener
por ejemplo sobre colombia pues ha
pasado muchas décadas de aspersión de
glifosato en una estrategia de la lucha
contra el narcotráfico
pues generado incalculables daños al
medio ambiente que también siempre van a
revertir en la salud de los campesinos
en este caso mala cambiamos ahora el
tema porque aprovechando que hoy es el
día del orgullo hablamos de salud de las
personas de la comunidad el g20 y comas
así es raúl lo estabas diciendo ahora en
el noticiero sabemos que es un día pues
de la celebración de la diferencia pero
también es un día para recordar porque
el orgullo es necesario en el mundo de
hoy en día vamos a repasar las cifras de
discriminación de personas lg pumas en
eeuu es uno de los países donde hay más
cifras disponibles son unas cifras de
una encuesta del 2017 vemos que las
personas pues que en este caso tienen
una orientación sexual no normativa
lesbianas gays bisexuales por ejemplo
denunciaron haber sido en un 8 por
ciento rechazados en las consultas
médicas por el personal de salud por su
orientación sexual
el 9 recibió lenguaje violento por
profesionales de la salud en cambio
estas cifras aumentan muchísimo cuando
hablamos de personas trans 29% 21% en
ambos casos es de nuestra reunión y
hablar en américa latina' por supuesto
qué consecuencias tiene esta
discriminación marc en materia de salud
pues lo hemos venido diciendo a lo largo
de otros programas las consecuencias son
nefastas básicamente porque alejan a
todas estas personas de la atención
médica del cuidado a su salud eso hace
que por ejemplo entre las mujeres
lesbianas o bisexuales las tasas de
cáncer de mama sean mucho más altas que
en mujeres heterosexuales sólo por
nombrar un ejemplo por qué sucede esto
pues porque hay menos de educación
asexual porque se investiga menos sobre
problemas específicos de todas las
personas lg vete y comas también porque
estas personas tiene una capacidad
económica mucho menor a raíz de las
discriminaciones pero es que además
queríamos terminar nombrando un caso
particular en el que vemos que todo esto
realmente afecta a la vida y la muerte a
veces es cuestión de vida o muerte
también la hemos recordado en este
programa
alejandra era una mujer trans
trabajadora sexual de bogotá que en
plena cuarentena en 2020 por la pandemia
de kobe una ambulancia porque no podía
respirar los profesionales de la salud
decidieron no atenderla por su condición
de mujer trans de trabajadora sexual y
por ser vih positiva y terminó
falleciendo entonces también hoy pues
recordar a esas personas que no pueden
celebrar un día como el orgullo porque
no está claro más lamentable bueno
espero que estas cifras no se repitan y
mejor dicho no aumenten más bien
disminuyan marc como siempre gracias por
toda la información de salud nos vemos
mañana miércoles